today in Taiwan people from all walks of
life are choosing to be stung by bees
often dozens of times in one city show
wrong Chen's battling multiple sclerosis
a disease which slowly causes the body's
nerve to deteriorate for six months I
was bedridden I could not move I would
have symptoms of tingling and numbness
in my hands it was excruciating pain
then show wrong heard about bee sting
therapy for help she turned to mr. Cheng
Yi Chen bee sting therapy master a
trained master who has practiced bee
sting therapy for 12 years every week
mr. Chen and his assistants treat 200
patients and sacrifice 6000 honeybees
the results he says can be astounding
after 600 bees you look five years
younger than your contemporaries but can
be stings really help show wrong fight
multiple sclerosis she began an
intensive course of therapy receiving
over 200 stings a week for months on end
honeybees only sting once and they died
soon after
but even separated from the bee the
Stinger continues to inject venom into
its victim the body responds with a
flood of histamines and white blood
cells and soon the area becomes hot red
swollen and itchy
anyone stay at home I don't even
time to feel the panel off he stinks me
again and the pan lasts for one hour
many think it is based on the five
thousand-year-old practice of
acupuncture a proven treatment for pain
although today mr. Chen sees bee
acupuncture as a labor of love even he
once considered it taboo in fact like
most of us he was afraid of bees thirty
years ago mr. Chen was an executive for
textiles company then his wife began to
suffer from arthritic pain so severe she
couldn't cook or even stand up straight
Western medicines didn't do much good
but when she told her husband she wanted
to get stung by bees he thought the idea
was ridiculous she's with naturally is
an educated man I was against it we just
did not understand bees but mr. Chen
completely changed his mind when he saw
his wife's sudden improvement after
three months her red blood cell count
increased her headache disappeared I was
so surprised I decided to dive into this
mysterious treatment and collect all the
information that I could mr. Chen vowed
to devote his life to bringing bee sting
therapy to others after six months of B
sting therapy show Rong Chen has seen a
dramatic change she insists the therapy
has relieved her multiple sclerosis and
given her a new lease on life
while most Western trained doctors would
likely say her illness is in remission
Cho Rong is convinced the stings have
helped her walk again it will take years
of study before we'll know whether bee
stings can relieve arthritis or multiple
sclerosis or even the common cold
but whether show wrongs recovery is in
her head or her hands and feet for the
first time in more than a year she feels
she can resume living a therapy most of
us would find taboo is allowing her to
face the future with renewed hope